[Music]
we're also gonna missing this couple
together Chris Pratt and Otto Ferris be
so sweet together but they're eating
your marriage crumbled of course and it
makes us think about quite a few other
Hollywood couples that we would never
want to see break up the Clooney's are
Hollywood's ultimate happy ending one of
the babies coming oh yes aren't you nice
smart funny and oh so stylish the human
rights attorney inspired George to
choose love over life as Hollywood's
most famous bachelor they said I Do's in
2014 and this summer
welcome twins Alexander and Jessica and
Justin are a couple that celebrates each
other's success an incredibly
understanding of her husband
shortcomings when they're now
two-year-old son Silas was toddling
around she stayed home while he toured
the globe promoting trolls but now it's
her turn to shine I don't want a lawyer
getting huge critical acclaim for her
new USA drama the sinner
Jessica told us her husband of nearly
five years couldn't be prouder he's
really excited for me she's down there
over there yeah yeah make it a shine now
almost five years into their marriage
Blanc and Ryan still make each other
blush but they're also the parents who
keep it real we keep our family together
we don't ever work at
and that's what that's what makes it
nice date nights are very important to
keep up with Kristen Bell and Dax
Shepard also keep laughter alive
[Music]
even when their nearly four-year merge
we had a couple years of debt week of
fighting and of growing pains and of
hating each other and going to couples
therapy but you know what we earned each
other John Legend and Chrissy Teigen are
not just the happiest social couple but
also the cheekiest leave me alone when
we first started dating he had clothes
that he had had since ninth grade
finally Rita Wilson helped Tom Hanks
prove nice guys can finish first it's
like oh uh you know I thought I loved
this woman six months ago but I loved
her even more now
ét heard tom gush about Rita even before
they were married
and if they can't make it work love
would officially be dead we got married
for all the right reasons we don't have
to it was a voluntary thing now all most
couples Tom and Rita have actually been
married the longest 29 years and in
Hollywood that is pretty amazing
[Music]